[Music]
My God, it
's a month of luck that we were able to sneak in here.
But you're a bad guy who looks like numbers. It
looks like today's topic is about Darius or the principal. It's already been four months since we lost touch with him.
It's strange to see him as dead. He
wasn't immature enough to accidentally die in the labyrinth, but that means he was killed by someone. Those who
did it, please raise your hand.
[Laughs]
Who would do something like this?  It wouldn't be strange if I tried. If I could
kill them, it would be these six guys from Garland.
[Music]
McFarlem, hey, hey, he was bought at a pretty high price. I
hope you guys are a little surprised that he went home.  It's hard to do this,
so don't
stir things up, Theodore
[Music] Excuse me,
Mr.
Headmaster. Things that are stagnant tend to want to be stirred up.And
none of them have anything to do with Darius' disappearance.
If I'm wrong, one of these will turn me into an enemy.
[Music] If I'm
prepared for it, I have nothing to say.Then I
won't pursue this matter from now on.By the way,
if it were a student who did it,
what would I do?  The only thing that doesn't change is that I
regret my own foolishness.
In despair and pain.